[Music]
all right let's I guess let's move on to
the Barbie trailer what's up oh whoa
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls this is the Barbie
trailer by the way yeah
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
foreign they knew what they were doing
with that shot why modernizing Barbie
why with the white toenail polish ah if
they were done yeah getting the dogs out
yep
[Music]
smash that baby yeah
Chuck that baby
[Music]
here's an interesting thing that they
bought little girls baby dolls and like
this is all you're gonna do practice
Yeah like asking them to smash them yeah
you're saying yeah yeah
no I mean like it's teaching little
girls like oh I see yeah yeah
you're gonna make one of these one day
yeah you're gonna get a real one yeah
anyway rest of the trailer
[Music]
hmm
you stoked yep
I'm in it you're in it
no way I didn't tell anyone what part do
you play I don't know yet
you're um
vague Barbie yeah
which one is that one from
foreign
I think he's a rock climber
like works on Mount Everest or something
yeah
it's kind of
Nineveh we don't know we don't know we
don't know
right guys dude looking hot you said it
have you seen the whale yet the whale
yeah
oh
now the one with Brendan Fraser the new
one no not yet I want to watch that have
you guys seen anyone here
we don't watch movies that are only
available on planes
what do you mean is a24
wow this is like his like comeback story
okay I mean that's not the story but I'm
saying like this is like this is one he
like stood up at the Venice film
festival and everyone applaused him for
right 38 minutes straight damn bro I
cannot
sorry I cannot see Zoom
meeting like
yeah Luke already knows what I'm
laughing at without thinking of that
dude who goes in hacks Zoom I know
that [ __ ] is so rude man it's bad it's
so bad it's really bad some School
District being like we need to buy more
crayons oh
I'm a bust
people that don't know how to use
computers
[Laughter]
no the budget's fine we have money for
it no look who is that in the corner who
is that in the corner they think that
they're talking about the meetings
hahaha
it's a [ __ ] court hearing
the arraignment of the defendant will
occur on oh I'm about to buy
what the hell
the [ __ ] is going on dude
you gotta be out of like always be on
defense on Zoom you know yeah just in
case that should happen to you ready to
end yeah exactly
dude we talked about [ __ ] about
Warhammer Henry cavill's getting his own
[ __ ] I know
he's getting what he's getting his own
film yeah but he's also getting cut from
he's not Superman anymore yeah why is
that because I don't know they're like
making a bunch of changes I guess like
the new director they're like he wants
to have a clean slate or something but
yet they're still making they're still
releasing Flash
yeah yeah and everyone's pointing out
Ezra Miller yeah
yeah like what the [ __ ]
that when is that movie supposed to come
out
oh so he's getting his own Warhammer
Series yeah
but it's with what is it what is he
doing uh I don't know is it like fantasy
or is it like them playing
Warhammer no It's gotta be like based on
the actual lore sick
yeah we'll see how it turns out it's so
funny because I the last time we
literally whenever it was last week
I was saying I think it'd be too
expensive
and here here we go
no riders or showrunners are attached
yet okay
when was The Flash supposed to be
released
what does that say it's June 16 next
year damn yeah well I'm stoked for this
Warhammer thing that sounds awesome
um oh it's Amazon though if it gets a
boys level budget I think it'll be okay
yeah Amazon has some good [ __ ] I just
finished peripheral what was that about
it's about a world where rich people
kind of control the future and there's
an Institute in the middle of it that
kind of figures out how to
alter time but in a programmatic way so
they can basically Fork time
sick they don't [ __ ] up the main
timeline they can just Fork out a new
okay reality and then they can go into
the main reality and make changes so
it would basically be like yeah you can
engineer a different reality and not
affect everyone else I see they
basically send these Advanced VR
headsets into the past
where people from the past are
controlling like humanoid robots
um in the future to accomplish things
yeah it's pretty interesting but it was
it was shot like doo-doo really
is it Apple TV or what is it it was on
Amazon
so does Amazon generally kind of like
[ __ ] things up I I that could be said
about any network but my experience with
Amazon shows is typically
it just feels like they lean on the
dialogue a lot
but they don't I don't know visually
it's just sort of
so they show a setting and then a bunch
of people talking and they show another
building and a bunch of people talking
the boys would say
a season one yeah I liked it I don't I
think I watched after season one maybe I
watched season two can't remember what I
can't I can't remember if I watched
season two
or is there two seasons or three no
there's like four Now isn't there
three no I think maybe I think I watched
one is it too but
I heard three had a lot of
um
I heard three fell flat because it was
kind of a lot of uh
political commentary and references that
were relevant a while ago
yeah also the story just gets kind of
weird
yeah
it's a tough idea I think to evolve
well the story was just so [ __ ] sick
for the first season it was like too
sick it was like that was it yeah and
then everything afterwards just kind of
feels like oh they're just like adding
[ __ ] on because the show is popular yeah
I think the premise of superheroes being
normal
there's not much you can do past one
season that's like super
mind-blowing I think that you just have
to like the premise yeah to keep going
on it also I find that Amazon shows like
a lot of the acting feels CW ish
it was really hand like
hammed up
I don't know we need more MILF shows
yeah that's the lesson yeah yeah